so what do i call you kitten or kitten
tits do you think uh kitten tits let's
go with kitten tits i think that's best
all right kitten tits uh where where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally um i'm born and raised
southern california
i technically was born in lompoc which
is a tiny little farmville up north up
by santa barbara
but i was only there it was so small i
was in the newspaper like it was a tiny
little town but we moved out within like
a week like i don't remember it all at
all um and i pretty much
grew up in the valley like okay what was
your family like growing up
um
it started out good um had a fairly
normal childhood at the beginning but
things got a little dysfunctional when i
got older i had two siblings and you
know loving mom and dad
they did the best
that they could with what they had but
having three kids
and having their own
issues that they were trying to work on
um unfortunately i don't think they had
the financial means to take care of us
you know we at some points didn't have a
roof over our head um you know we were
on welfare all the time
there was a long period of my life where
we lived in and out of hotels and motels
and just
it was a very i don't know ugly part of
my life um
but uh
yeah that was kind of i guess i was kind
of um i don't know when
when my life kind of started to change
what were you like as a teenager as a
teenager um i was like an emo kid so
i was i was super
i was super depressed um
and i did
i was a self-mutilator um
so i kind of
i had a really pessimistic outlook on a
relationship so like at the point in my
life when
i should have been dating and having
crushes and inviting people over to my
house and even just like friendships not
even just like relationships whether
it's friendships like
i couldn't do that because i didn't want
anyone to know like oh we're living in a
hotel or
oh like
we have to um bring our food stamps in
to get enough change so that my mom can
buy cigarettes like i didn't want
anybody to know like what was going on
in my
was that was it life poverty the biggest
factor in your childhood development or
was there some abuse as well um
no
i mean there was domestic abuse between
my parents but nothing um like we we
weren't touched we weren't um so the
poverty was the biggest factor
definitely yeah um
yeah i mean yeah we saw a lot of
violence um like we would but they would
try to hide it from us
um
and there was a lot of um
violence between your mom and dad and
alcohol and drug abuse
as well yeah but yeah they they would
try to hide it but we would hear the
fighting
um and then once we were living in hotel
rooms there's five people in one room
it's kind of hard to keep that away so
we saw some of it and
so but it never um it never
happened to us
which i'm very thankful for very
grateful for but it kind of um
i guess
so i don't want to like feel like i'm
blaming my parents because i don't think
they're at fault um if anything i i want
to thank them because like that's
everything that happened in my childhood
brought me to where i am today you know
like everyone everyone's life and their
choices
and the decisions that they may kind of
bring them to where they are so i'm
i don't want to blame them but um
i didn't have a
a good um i didn't have a good
representation of what a healthy
relationship
should be like
and that led me down a really ugly path
um
i definitely i feel like my my first
real relationship was with pain like
because that's what i turned to and i
don't even know what what set off that
first
that first urge but i know that it was
when i was going through all that [ __ ]
like with my family and just struggling
not having friends
yeah i felt very lonely
and the only kind of coping and stress
relief that i had was to hurt myself
and usually it was cutting um
eventually it evolved into like burning
i do have some burns
on my body um
i have some really ugly scars on my body
that i don't
self self-inflicted for the most part
there's a few that other people have
done
so today as an adult you are what you
call submissive
yes
yeah um i identify with being a
submissive and i do identify with being
a masochist as well so
basically my uh
i still do enjoy pain but i don't do it
to myself anymore
um you find you find partners to do it
for you yeah i found i found partners to
do it for me and then i also find
clients to do it for them you do this
professionally as well as personally
yes yes um
it's a huge part of my personal life i
just i truly enjoy even the softer side
of it but i really am
i'm a bit of a pain [ __ ]
if you will
but uh
yeah yeah i do i do it professionally as
well
i have worked at a dungeon in the past
but currently i'm just booking my own
clients on my own time partially because
of the pandemic and partially because
it's just way more convenient i can set
my own times at my own prices set my own
boundaries so
it works better so you have a
regular job as well oh yeah yeah yeah i
i have a um i have a day job i have a
nine to five it's a desk job
okay we will get into what that is but
um so so
as far as being a submissive
tell me how what does this look like
what kind of
behavior does this
um bring you into
everything under the umbrella of bdsm so
bdsm is an overlapping acronym so the b
and the d stand for bondage
and discipline the d and the s stand for
dominance and submission
and the s and the m stand for
sadism and masochism or sadomasochism
so i'm into a little bit of all of that
but for the most part i enjoy being like
the
the object that is being used or being
tied up or being objectified or being
degraded or being hurt there are a
couple fetishes that i like to switch
which means i will would be the top or
the dominant in that role um that's more
for like some of my darker fetishes and
some of my more personal fetishes i
don't typically like to get paid for
those ones
but i'm into
everything from water sports
feet play
i do like being a human ashtray
but that does often result in burning so
i try to be really really really really
careful about who i play with um and and
make sure that um i'm you know not
getting any permanent marks that i don't
want
um
but
yeah
a regular conventional normal i guess i
don't know what word to use
person vanilla vanilla
would not make a good partner for you
because you want something a little more
extreme right um
yes and no
uh i would say my current relationship
is kind of vanilla but we get into some
kinky stuff in the bedroom but it's not
he's not a sadist he doesn't like to
beat the [ __ ] out of me he doesn't want
to see marks on my body he doesn't want
to make me bleed but
but you'd be open to that but um but no
he's willing to let me go and get my
kicks elsewhere if i need to he's open
to that but like he likes to tie me up
you know he likes to be called daddy and
you know there are things like that that
we get into and i really enjoy um but
for the most part on the outside like we
don't have a structured ds um like
things like that um
you know that would be more of a
dominant submissive relationship and
that's not what i have but i have a
boyfriend
that i do fetish play with if that makes
sense and so you're also you do this
professionally so that means you're also
doing things outside your relationship
where you are
being paid
to do what to be a um to be a submissive
so
really
everything
fetish and kink and in bdsm that is
not sexual
and i understand that that could be a
big gray area and a lot of times i do
have to turn down sessions because
people are looking for something a
little more sexual
for me
that the line where i draw the line is
basically at fluid exchange and
penetration
that's not going to happen in my
sessions
plenty of people are into that
especially um you know dominatrixes they
do a lot of pegging
they do a lot of spinning in the mouth
like that's
that's that's sex to me so i don't i try
to draw the line um and then like i said
some some clients are looking for
something sexual and even when i very
very straightforward explain to them
there will be no sex in the session
they'll still ask they will still ask oh
does that mean i can get a blow job does
that mean i can get a hand job does that
mean i can get a foot job i have to be
like no i'm sorry it sounds like you're
looking for something else i do hope you
find what you're looking for like i i'm
willing to turn down sessions that don't
feel like they're good fit
or or feel like they're possibly unsafe
so it's really not a sexual thing
professional professional not for me no
um i can separate the two
some of my fetishes do turn me on though
so if i'm playing like i may get turned
on if someone's you know putting clothes
pins on my nipples or hitting me with a
flogger like yeah that's arousing but
i'm not going to let them touch me
sexually i'm not going to let that most
extreme the degradation gets
for me um
i really like um like licking the bottom
of boots and having boots like put on my
face like in the bottom of shoes are
disgusting like right now if you ask me
to lick your shoe i would say absolutely
not you're out of your mind
it's a headspace it's a
you got to be in the right mood you got
to be playing with the right person
it really it has to be like it has to be
a good fit i don't want to do that with
just anybody i want to do that with the
right person um also like uh like
bathroom play like being peed on um
having my head shoved in a toilet like
that stuff that i've done but only with
the right partners
um and like i said human ashtray is one
of my favorites so i that's something
that i'm comfortable enough i would do
that with a session but i would not let
them put a cigarette out on my skin and
leave a mark
so i i know where my boundaries are but
having to explain that to a client
sometimes takes a while and i'm willing
to negotiate as long as it takes to
figure out if it's going to work or not
and there's so many ways of looking at
this i'm sure that some of the viewers
will be like oh this is
terrible that you're doing this it's
degrading and all that but you could
also argue that you're not hurting
anyone
no it's all consensual
yeah and i mean everything that i do i'm
i am enjoying and i'm doing because i
want to do it it's on like i said on my
time my terms
what do you think it stems from
do you think from that that that love of
pain i
seeing what happened with your mom and
dad
um
i never thought about it like that but i
don't think that was a direct
correlation
i mean maybe because i was the only
relationship i really saw growing up
that like i said i was didn't really
know what a healthy relationship looked
like
and actually with that being said in my
personal life i did come across
a terrible person who abused me and
traumatized me
even though i thought it was consensual
because it was under the terms of ds
so do you think it's just your
just the way your brain
works naturally or is it uh i do i think
i'm wired this way you just wire this
way i think i'm wired this way i've
tried
therapy counseling i've tried to stop
i've tried uh
medication
just thinking that maybe i'm just too
depressed or something but no it's
something that i crave constantly i want
it if i don't get it for a certain
amount of time i'm gonna want it more
we are who we are it really is um yeah
we are who we are it's it's
it's akin to an addiction uh in that
sense though you know like it's
something that like it's that stress
relief it's that like ah feeling it's
just it's it's my happy place that's
getting your head shoved in the toilet
getting your boot against your face if
if if the scene was set up right yes
you can't just do it with any everybody
anybody exactly that that's a that's a
really big important thing and and i do
want to take a moment to say that
not all of
us kinksters and fetishes we don't all
stem from
a you know being molested or being
abused i know that's a very common
misconception in the scene so i just
want to take a moment to say that yeah
i'm sure there's many cases where it is
and there's many cases where it's not
yeah
the one thing that that did happen that
i would say um
because of what i saw as a child i ended
up in a very toxic relationship and
because it was under the umbrella of ds
and under the guise of diaz
i basically was letting someone abuse me
it was not consensual all the time
um
so yeah
there there are some bad people out
there even though when i when i found
the scene and i discovered
that there's a whole community of people
out there who are into this
i felt like i found a family and i felt
like i finally found somewhere i
belonged because these people understood
like i wasn't i wasn't a freak i mean i
am a freak but it wasn't like
i wasn't an outsider anymore i wasn't
like the black sheep i finally like
found my people and then
you still have to be aware of
of the narcissists and the abusers and
the people that take advantage of
you know willing submissive so
yeah was there a significant romantic
relationship in your
past that maybe
put you in a into a submissive
role
that
you're recreating somehow
no um
i've i've always wanted to play this
role um
i i had a really pessimistic outlook on
relationships when i was younger i was
really cynical um so i didn't even start
dating until i was like 18
and i ended up marrying my first
boyfriend if that like puts things in
perspective of like because i thought i
was doing the right thing and i was
gonna settle down and get married and
you know he he was going to school and
he was a good guy and we got we started
going to the dungeon together um you
know so and he was on board and he was
the one that didn't want to be in the
relationship eventually for whatever
reason
um
so that was that wasn't a bad
relationship and
if i look back on it um in retrospect it
it ended kind of sad but it was what it
was so there's a dungeon
and there's a dungeon tell me about the
dungeon um
so the dungeon i found
well there's a lot of them let me start
there um there's several of them
unfortunately a couple of them have
closed down due to the pandemic which is
devastating but
hopefully
somebody is able to you know
open another one um
but uh yeah there's a couple of them but
i've only worked at one there are a
couple of uh other ones you can actually
work um you know as as on staff as
either a dominant a switch or a
submissive
and i had a great time there
but
i honestly i'm glad i don't work there
anymore because
a lot of times you feel like you have to
take the session that comes in the door
um
and i like to like i was explaining
earlier i like to be able to negotiate
and turn sessions down if i need to
um based on the
the vibe you get from the person exactly
yeah and sometimes working at the
dungeon you'd be in a lineup and they
would expect you to put in your all and
do everything you can to get the session
and even if you didn't even if like if i
was sitting in an interview with a
potential client and i feel the vibe is
off i'm gonna try to give him the
answers so that he doesn't pick me
he might still pick me because he likes
what i'm wearing or he likes how i look
or maybe he liked my little attitude i
don't know what it is but sometimes the
people you don't want to play with still
pick you and then you have to play with
this person
i didn't like that um
and on top of that's where you're doing
it for money
yeah at that point in my life i needed
the money and
a lot of people um
especially submissives because that's an
easier role to play you don't actually
need skills
um a lot of girls
started working there and were new and
i don't know fell down a rabbit hole or
something because
there was some ugly [ __ ] that went on
behind the closed doors there um
tell me about
the bdsm community in general
in general is it a fairly happy
pleasant bunch to hang out with or is it
yeah is there a lot of demented
it's um i mean there's a handful of
demented people out there just like
there is everywhere but for the most
part
i would say it's really supportive um
they're very inclusive
they they really do feel like a family
for the most part and then
although there might be some people that
kink shame for the most part we try not
to shame each other for the things that
we're into you probably all understand
each other
it to some extent yeah each other yeah
like
even like you you might be in defeat i
might be into putting my head in the
toilet we might not both be into those
by vice versa but hey that's cool we can
hang out and you know chat over a beer
that's still all right you know like uh
the the the dungeon has uh events and
parties and there's um what what we call
munches
munches are basically just
meat meet-and-greets or meet-ups at like
a restaurant or like a potluck it's a
very
non-kink environment for people that are
either brand new
or like trying to get into like a
specific niche like there's there'll be
rope munches
um there'll be a ddlg munches or adult
baby play lunches um they'll be you know
pet play munches and they'll be like
full blown events like where they give
out awards and they have like pet shows
and like um
there's an event that happens once a
year here in l.a and also once in new
orleans and it's literally like a
three-day long convention
is this a large community like we're in
los angeles is a large community here
definitely in l.a yeah but there there's
a lot of freaks everywhere yeah we're
out there but the bigger the bigger and
more populated the area i think that's
you're gonna get a more
dense amount of kinksters within that
more robust support yeah
i think we're i think we're a growing
percentage of the poppy population so
i think it's becoming more mainstream
which
although i appreciate i think it kind of
i don't know
it leaves a bad taste in my mouth
sometimes when i see people that are
like wearing latex and you know wearing
the the fetish masks and stuff and i
don't believe they're actually into it i
think they're just doing it for the
fashion thing the people that wear
collars don't really know what that
means
it's like okay that's cute but there's
like real meaning behind some of that
stuff for some people like
and are drugs a part of this scene or
for you yeah me i smoke a lot of weed
but um other than that and and i drink i
like to drink uh occasionally but um no
i don't do any hard drugs i'm sure a lot
of other people do um
and i know
i don't know if poppers are considered a
hard drug but the way that they're used
i think they are because they're
damaging to the brain um but they're
really big in um in bdsm because when
you
do that thing when you get the head
cleaner it makes you be able to take a
lot of pain
i've seen people that can't even take a
slap they'll see poppers and you can
beat them till they're bloody
and also that allows for like some
really intense anal play like you can
get really
extreme
because you're not really feeling the
pain
i don't like that
i want to feel the pain
um i like the endorphins i like the rush
i like pushing my my limits and finding
out where they are so yeah but there are
people that yeah they partake and do
dangerous things while under the
influence in the non-sexual
areas of your life are you also kind of
into this
uh submissive pain
yeah oh yeah um maybe in the workplace
or something like that uh
i don't know about the workplace but
like even when i'm having casual days at
home um
oh i mean i guess i don't know like
it's just in your personality broad
question yeah it is like i'll ask my
boyfriend if i could take his shoes off
when he gets home like he's he doesn't
care if i take his shoes off he'll do it
himself but that makes me feel good um
you know i'll dress up in cute lingerie
and make dinner and you know i really
like wearing collars so like if he
is gonna buy me a gift that's probably
gonna be related to our play um
let's see
at work like people at work know
that i'm kinky but they don't know the
full extent of what i'm into they don't
ask questions um it's just kind of
ironic because
uh i actually i work
for a manufacturer that makes sex toys
so i'm kind of in the adult industry on
both sides
and it's really funny you can't get away
from it
i love it though it makes me happy um
and i want to make other people
understand that it's okay too but
it's funny because the adult industry
when it comes to like the products and
even some of the porn
they're kind of vanilla like they kind
of kink shame they're like oh you guys
are you guys are the freaks like you
know like we're different um we're like
a subgroup in the industry but
yeah i pretty much have to be vanilla at
the office for the most part even though
people kind of know
it's hard to hide
i think i used to think i was
i was totally under the radar i thought
everyone was oblivious
to what i was into
and when i started telling some of my
friends like friends that i had kept
from like school like middle school and
high school and stuff and i finally told
them like yeah i'm into this stuff i
went to the dungeon they're like yeah
that figures i was like what
how did you know
yeah so i think i uh i think it just
exudes from my my person
just who i am
i mean what what message would you
want to give to
an audience who's maybe
skeptical about how healthy this is or
how
or maybe they're interested in it
um if anyone's skeptical skeptical about
how healthy it is
um just know there's a lot of education
out there
and there is a lot of support and
anyone who takes bdsm seriously
practices
either
what we call ssc
but that's kind of an older term it's
been replaced with r-a-c-k rack
ssc used to stand for
safe sane and consensual kink so
you want to make sure you're being safe
sane and consensual
well we kind of realized that we're not
always being really safe and we're not
always being
um
insane we're not always being sane
so even though
okay so then the new word that replaced
it is rack risk awareness consensual
kink
so even though you might be doing
something that's a little dangerous
maybe you're letting someone hang you
from hooks hanging from rope
asphyxiating you choking you till you
pass out
there's all uh mummifying you there's
all sorts of things that could be
dangerous but you want to be aware of
your risks and you want to make sure
that the person you're playing with is
also aware of those risks
that's the safest way to play and i
would not encourage anyone to play
otherwise
but there's still going to be people
that do that
and then the people that are interested
and want to get into this i say go for
it
not to sound cheesy but you do only live
once this is the only life you get
and i used to think that i lived my life
with no regrets
and what i've come to find out is that
i would rather live my
life and regret something that i did
than
to regret something that i didn't do
because i'd rather experience it and
know for a fact that i either don't like
it or maybe i do or maybe i'll try it
again a little different next time
instead of wondering what if
that
that would be what i'd say to people
just try it
excellent all right kitten thank you so
much for sharing your story and
enlightening us a little bit about this
thank you mark this was a pleasure thank
you very much
you